私は地域の中で様々な人がスポーツを通して集い
その輪がどんどん広がっていきますように
いろんな活動をしています
いろんな世代の人たちが参加できる陸上競技クラブを主宰しています
これは小学生のブロックですこのように走ったり
鬼ごっこをしたり
ハードルをしたり
走り幅跳びをしたり
大人のランニングブロックですフルマラソンの完走を目指したり健康のために
ジョギングをする人たちがいます
中学生上のアスリートブロックですこの中には全国大会に出場するような選手もいます
したバー6歳から上は80歳くらいまでの人が参加をします
毎回練習には150名くらいの参加があります
なので
このように親子で参加をしたり
ご夫婦で参加をしたい
当然兄弟で参加をしたり
これは私の子供です
6年生4年生1年生1年生の女子がかなり不機嫌な顔しますけど
これはのただお腹がすいてるだけこの後食事を与えたら機嫌よくなりました
おばあちゃんとお孫さんと一緒に来たり3世代で通えるスポーツクラブです
スポーツだけではなくこのようにクリスマスパーティーをしたりスポーツを通したた
世代のコミュニティです
50m 1分以内で走りきれる人なら誰でも参加できるスポーツイベントを主催してい
ます
ご覧ください右から中学生ぐらいの女の子
高校生ぐらいの男の子大人の女性
男性おじいちゃんが真剣にかけっこ消防しています
とってもいい勝負をしています誰が勝つかわかりません
こんな写真見たことないと思います
こんなちっちゃな子も出場しますアニメのキャラクターに釣られながら
してますが
本当につられている名前のところこれ
これに泣きわめきながら走る思っ
日本のスポーツチームというのはほとんどが同世代で構成されます
少し少年団部活動学生のサークル
ママさんバレーボールチームゲートボールチーム
よってスポーツイベントとかスポーツ大会も
世代を区切られて開催されるものがほとんどです
中学生の大会とか社会での大会とか
皆さんにとってそれはもう当たり前ごく当たり前の光景だと思うんですけれども
今ご覧いただいたように私はいろんな世代の人たちが参加できるスポーツクラブ
そしてスポーツイベントを主催しています
なぜそのようなことをするようになったのか今日はお話をしたいと思います
元はへ
野球少年です
小学校中学校でずっと野球をやっていました
中学校の時に
主野球部に所属をしながら陸上の大会に出ました
すると o まあまあいいタイムが出まして
で
でこの高校では
野球をそのままするか野球部に入るか
陸上部に入るか悩み始めました
どっちのスポーツが自分に合ってるだろうな
陸上競技を選んだわけですけれども最終的な理由は
坊主頭にしなくていいと
3年間坊主頭でしたのでも思春期ですから
モテたいとそれだけですね
ここから陸上競技をはじめまして髪を伸ばしながら
高校3年生の頃には全国大会で入賞するようになりました
インターハイとか国体
それぐらいの頃から
将来はここに
日の丸の入っている日本来たいな
日本代表オリンピック
夢見るようになりました
大学は中央大学という
非常に伝統のある強豪陸上部のある大学に進学をしました
陸上部に入るともうすでに先輩とか同級生には世界大会に行くような人たちもいてそう
いう人たちの身近に接することで日本代表
オリンピック
思いをますます強くしました
大学3年4年くらいになるともうマリア就職活動を始めるんですけれども
私は大学卒業した後も陸上競技を続けたい
その想い一つでした
そんな時にこの鹿児島に
実業団の陸上を持つ企業がありましてそこの監督さんから声をかけていただいて
実業団陸上部に入部することが決まりました
それが私がこの鹿児島に来た理由です
ちょうど20年前の話になります
この鹿児島を拠点として実業団の陸上部短距離選手として日々トレーニング
そして大会とか合宿も日本全国いろんなところへ行きました
北海道から沖縄まで
海外の大会にも参加したことがあります
夢を追っていました
話は変わりますけれども
20年と言えば何でしょう
言いませんか東京オリンピックパラリンピックですねはい
とても楽しみです加えてあの2020年は鹿児島で国体も開催されます
覚えておいてください
話を元に戻します鹿児島に来て5年が経ちました
2000年という年を迎えました
もう堪忍して今ピンときたかもしれません
先ほど2020年
東京オリンピックと言いましたオリンピックは4年に1度ですね
2000年もオリンピック嫌でした
私は28歳という年齢を迎える年になっていました
このオリンピックというのを夢見ながら選手生活を送れるのも
最後かもしれない心のどこかでそう思っていました
なのでこの2000年という年は自分の最高のパフォーマンスができる年にしたい
そう思っていました
ところが
忘れもしません
2000年3月23日
陸上部員全員が集められて
3月いっぱいをもっての陸上部の廃部が告げられました
プチ前でした
大変大きなショックを受けました
深い憤りを覚えました
そこでまず私が下した決断は
こんなところで終わってなるものか
こんな形で終わってなるものか
まだ走り続ける
辞表を書きまして
会社を辞めました
先のことなんか何も考えていませんでしょ
晴れて無職になりましたので
私には時間がたっぷりあります
好きな時に好きなだけトレーニンできます
陸上部の廃部の発表からしばらくトレーニングが中断していましたけれども
一日も早くトレーニングを再開して
コンディションを整えてもう目前に迫った
この2000年のオリンピックいあ戦い抜いてやるぞ
そう思っていました
心と体のバランスが崩れてきました
自分は今まで一体何をやってきたんだろう
スポーツって
ものだ
ちっちゃい頃から周りの大人にそう言われて育ってきましたスポーツどんどんやり
なさい
私もスポーツが大好きでしたいろんなスポーツをやりました
体育の授業が大好きでした
たまたま自分に合ったスポーツが見つかって記録が伸びて
実業団選手になっていっ
そして
最後に
あなたたちは会社のお荷物だっ
言われた
スポーツって何なんだろう
スポーツ選手って体
会社のお荷物
社会のお荷物なんだろうか
自分は今まで
いったい何をやってきたんだろう
無職になってまでなを走ろうとして自分は何がしたいんだろう
もしこの先
夢がかなったとして
それが何なんだろう
今まで0.01秒
速く走るために全てをかけてきた
でもそれに何の意味があるのか
そう思ってしまったんです
当然
練習に身が入りません
調子はガタガタガタガタだっ
落ちていきます
あんなに憧れていた私の夢は
あっという間に消えて遠い闇の向こうに行ってしまいました
この頃の私は
精神的にも大変落ち込んでいました
なんでこんなことになってしまうんだろう
自分は何にも悪いことしてないのに
何一つ悪いことしないのになんでこんなことになってしまうんだろう
何が悪いんだろう誰が悪いんだろう
毎日毎日行っていました
そしてその日も同じようにとある友人と会って
グダグダグダグダ文句言ってました
するとその友人は黙って私の話を聞いてくれた後
静かにこう言いました
大変な経験をしたね
でも
今全国でいろんな企業が
運動部を手放している
行き場を失ったスポーツ選手や指導者が
全国にたくさんいるはず
その人たちは何をしているの
こういうことが問題だと思うのであれば
問題だって
言わないといけないんじゃないの心を起こさないといけないんじゃないの
自分は何も悪くありません誰か助けてください
自分で立ち上がろうとしないものに誰も手を差し伸べてはくれないよ
頭を
ガーンと殴られたような気持ちというのは
まさにこういうことでした
言い返す言葉は一つも見つかりませんでした
家に帰って
黙って考えました
それまでは
自分は何も悪くない
周りのせいで自分が今こういう状況に置かれている
そう思い込んでいました
でも
あなたにできることがあるんじゃないの
そう言われました
自分に出来る事って
何だろう
この時矢印がぐるんと回ったんです
自分にできることってなんだろう
数日間考えました
そして
絵を書きました
従来の日本のスポーツ構造
ジュニアのスポーツから始まり中学高校大学あ日本のスポーツって
まずほとんどが学校で行われるスポーツなんだな
じゃ学校卒業したあとどうするのか一部のトップ選手だけが集められ
宣伝広告として企業スポーツプロ実業団というところに行くんだ
こういうシステムになってるな
このシステムのいいところもありますが
いろんな問題も抱えている子どもたちの体力低下の問題
スポーツが世代で区切られているからスポーツを通した世代間の交流が少ない
学校で行うスポーツがほとんどですから学校卒業するとスポーツをするば機械というの
が途端に減ってしまう
運動不足の大人がたくさんいます
ドキッとしたしてみませんか
大丈夫ですはい
運動不足で健康を害している人もたくさんいます
そして一部のトップ選手だけを集めた企業スポーツというのは企業の業績に大きく左右
される
いろんな問題を抱えているな
じゃ
これからの新しいスポーツというのはどうあるべきだろうか
スポーツの底辺っていうのは年齢とか学校とか企業とそういうものではなくて
スポーツをしたいと思った人が
誰でもいつでも地域の中で気軽に参加できる
そういう場がまずは必要なんじゃないか
そういうベースの中から少しずつレベルの高い選手も育っていく今までは財源的な意味
も込めて
企業とか学校が丸々スポーツを抱えていたわけですね
そこからスポーツが事実をする
自分たちで財源を持つ
そういう自立したスポーツスタイルに対して
学校とか企業というのはバックアップする
そういう側にもあるこういうスポーツシステムを作れないだろうか
地域の中で
いろんな世代の人たちがスポーツのもとに集い
コミュニティが生まれその輪がどんどん広がっていきますように
スポーツコミュニケーションサークル頭文字を取って
scc という名前の地域スポーツクラブを立ち上げよう
自分にできることはこれなんじゃないか
そう思いました
陸上部の廃部から3ヶ月号
2000年の7月1日
scc は代表私一人
会員は3人という
小さな小さな地域スポーツクラブとして活動を始めました
私の大好きな写真の一つです
scc のクラブの会員の皆さんが毎年
24時間駅伝というイベントに参加をします
24時間みんなでたすきをつないだ後にゴールはみんな一緒になって
ゴールをします
スタートと書いてますけどゴールです
みんなの笑顔が最高です
cc は設立からちょうど14年が経ちました
今会員数は700名という組織になりました
私は
陸上競技の選手としては
夢が叶いませんでした
それに対する挫折感というのは実は今も残っています
でも
夢がかなわなかったあなただから
できることがあるんだよって築かせてもらいました
私があの時あのまま自分が置かれている状況を
人の性
周りの整理したままだったならば今の私はありません
自分にできることは何か
矢印をぐるんと回して考えてみる
行動してみる
その一歩が
皆さん一人一人の10年後を作るのかもしれません
皆さん一人一人にできることは何でしょうか
ありがとうございました